und zwar wenn ich jetzt einen rahmen
hier dran platziere und da ist das rein
packe dann sehe ich darüber dass der
ananas aka-aki stelle ich meine lieben
freund und herzlich willkommen zurück zu
einer weiteren facts folge hier am
dienstag das habe ich jetzt im gegensatz
zum kontakt mal passend hingekriegt
ich hoffe wieder dass ihr hierdurch
jetzt ein bisschen was lernt oder
weniger sei mehr oder weniger alt ich
habe wieder ein paar geile sachen
rausgesucht beziehungsweise wurden wir
zu gesendet wie immer ich kann nicht für
die für die richtigkeit gar nicht kann
nicht garantiert aber nicht dass es
irgendwo in anderen videos auf youtube
schon mal vorgekommen ist
da kann ich nicht garantieren ist wurde
mir allerdings von verschiedenen leuten
hier zugesendet und zwar von raphael
effect 1 der mir dass alle an die mail
gesendet haben an meine kontrast
gmail.com wohin sind könnt und zwar wenn
ich hier einen zaun habe dann kann ich
ja normalerweise da nicht gegen springt
hüpft ihr dagegen die stars ananas geht
sogar höher als der fan aber ich kam da
irgendwie nicht drauf warum komme ich da
nicht drauf ganz einfach wenn ich ein
teppich darauf lege komme ich drauf das
ist so sinnvoll wie weiß nicht was
obwohl ich jetzt sogar vier viel höher
bin also es schon wenn ich jetzt hier
mal so mache ich bin viel viel höher als
dieser zone eigentlich ist ich fühle
mich auch in die viel viel höher so
fühle ich mich viel mehr am boden
man wird quasi so hoch gebaut wenn man
da drauf ist als wenn man als er noch
ein halber blog drauf man sieht auch
dass dieser zaun wenn ich mal dass man
eben so machen dass dieser teppich
einfach so in dem zaun so hallt noch mit
drin ist und da ich liege quasi der
liegt quasi darauf aber wenn man das ist
das ist ein fauxpas jetzt hat sich
einfach so ein quatsch blocken
also dieser zaun dieser teppich müsste
eigentlich in diesem zaun hier mit drin
sein weil ich ja offenbar nicht
aufbringen kann aber hier drauf ja
irgendwie schon aber hier bin ich jetzt
sogar noch ein höherer sind dass es
irgendwie total happy und total
interessanter fakt irgendwie ja ist halt
einfach fact nummer eins so fällt nummer
zwei wurde mir zugesendet von nico und
zwar hat es etwas mit dem inventar und
dem creative mode zu tun und zwar wenn
ich jetzt hier in dem inventar bin und
ich sehe jetzt hier ein schwammen da
kann ich jetzt einfach zum beispiel wenn
ich jetzt sieben drücke dann wird dieser
schwamm hier
slot reinkommen weil jetzt kommt hier
von halten komplettes beck 64 da rein
also wenn ich zum beispiel einfach jetzt
sage ich hab da so viele bäume und es
ist zum beispiel so oder ich möchte
unbedingt ganzen see machen wenn man
einen wassereimer hat ist ja glaub ich
sogar leer wenn ich den sätze oder der
lernt er ist sogar noch folgendes
beispiel was fast was ist denn lea wenn
man das setzt
was ist dann leer das hier ist es hier
mittlerweile so oder ich glaube sogar
wenn ich hier habe ich sogar noch ein ja
okay stimmt es gibt doch gibt es nicht
irgendwelche items ist wenn ich die
sätze dass die dann weg sind ich glaub
ist es bei knochenmehl so ich bin mir
nicht mehr sicher ob überhaupt
eigentlichen items so ist allerdings
kann ich jetzt zb auf 1 drücken wenn ich
64 diamanten auf dem slot 1 haben will
wenn ich allerdings jetzt eisenbahnen
auf sport1 haben will kann ich auch
wieder 1 drücken dann habe ich die hier
kann auch jetzt alles hier so komplett
hier voll machen jetzt alle möglichen
zahlen drücken und jetzt ein bisschen
hin und her jetzt habe ich hier quasi
alles voll mit ganz vielen verschiedenen
sachen und kaka und der dritte feld
wurde mir zugesendet von crazy dragon 0
3 0 2 und bands war habe ich jetzt eine
wunderschöne melonen stellt morgens
bevor das ist eine art das ist eine
ananas deswegen möchte ich diese methode
zu einer ananas um form sein einfaches
ananas ananas conny ich weiß nicht ob es
nicht so zu langen es aber egal so so
jetzt habe ich an das lka conny und zwar
wenn ich jetzt einen rahmen hier dran
platziere und da als das rein packe dann
sehe ich darüber dass der ananas aka
conti steht also wenn ich da drauf gucke
sehe ich das nicht darauf auch nicht
oder irgendwo drumherum
ich muss schon direkt auf die seite mit
dem namen drücken und dann sehe ich dass
da an als katy steht und jetzt wenn ich
das so drehe passiert hat nichts mit dem
schriftzug sondern das ganze bleibt
einfach drüberstehen das geht bis ich
quasi diesem blog ich mir angucke das
heißt bis hierhin und alles ist weg und
das ist auf jeden fall sehr cool vor
allem für adventures vielleicht wenn man
dann irgendwie da rein so ein blog macht
und dann macht man irgendwie dann ist
ein blog drin dann schreibt man oben
drüber rechts aber das nur recht geben
wenn da dann auch ein erdloch ist oder
irgend sowas da gibt es auf jeden fall
bestimmt ganz ganz viele coole ideen und
ja kommen wir zum fun fact meine damen
und herren und zwar wird mit dieser fun
fact zugesendet von grant kräftig amax
und zwar kann ich hier jetzt einfach mal
welche den creative g und jetzt als
zieht einfach village ein gebe neue welt
erstellen
er meinte ich sollte auf jeden fall als
fun fact vorstellbar ist echt cool ist
irgendwie richtig witzig fand fade fand
es witzig sondern einfach nur so was
passiert da jetzt und zwar spawn man
direkt neben einem village direkter
nehme schon noch ein bisschen laufen
aber ich wohne in diesem fall direkt
nebenan wird und wir haben hier auch
dahinter mit wasser hier lava also das
crazy ein pferde direkt am start und wir
haben eine schmiede und zwar haben wir
in den schmieder ich weiß nicht was da
drin haben das halt immer ein bisschen
unterschied obwohl ich glaube bei dem
sich das gleich werden wir direkt so
eine art standardausrüstung man einmal
direkt zur standardausrüstung am anfang
und zwar sachen wie jetzt ein helm oder
eine eisenbahn schütz und inventar
geöffnet ein bisschen was zu fressen und
dann kann man hier direkt loslegen wir
haben hier hinten direkt bäume hier am
start da sind direkt bäume wir haben
hier ferne wir haben hier war lava
wasser höhlen alles ein perfekter start
in eine tolle welt also freunde fun fact
hier village eingeben und bekommt auch
wirklich ein wild in der 1.752 zumindest
ich glaube 1.754 wird es auch so sein
oder den snapshot auch da verändern sie
eigentlich nie was am generator und
sonst würd ich sagen meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lasst doch bitte eine positive bewertung
da das zeigt mir dass es euch gefallen
hat und ja gibt einfach den daumen hoch
reckt den daumen nach oben die sonst was
und jetzt könnt ihr mir wie immer per
mail an kontakt kommen und dann sehen
uns beim nächsten mal